[Music]
let's go out to Philadelphia and talk to
Lynn what's up
Lynn hi Dr John how are you good how are
you I am nervously sweating right now
but I'm okay I'm excited to talk to you
you get the nervous
sweats oh yeah definitely I kind of do
too it's freezing where you are isn't it
it is yeah it's getting cold so there's
no reason to be sweating right now well
especially because I'm not very good at
this but we'll figure it out all right
so how can I help what's
up so my boyfriend told me yesterday
that he found some text messages on my
phone I actually sent you an email last
week saying that I think I've had an
emotional affair with a married
cooworker at my remote job my boyfriend
wants to forgive me and work through
this together so my main question is how
do I Salvage my relationship with my
boyfriend and talk to him about it I
really don't know where to begin or how
I got
here yeah so what happened forget
boyfriend forget put boyfriend over to
the side what
happened so I have been with this
company for like three years and I took
a position about a year and a half ago
where I started to work more one-on-one
uh even though it's a completely remote
job I started to have more one-on-one
sessions with my
co-workers and I that's where I met the
cooworker
um and at first he just was really nice
to me and and would send me like funny
memes through like the the platform that
we work through or like send me a song
that he liked or something and um I
thought that it was really just a
friendship which is why didn't set up
really firm boundaries at the time but
then he started kind of just like
complimenting me a lot telling me that
he thought I was really smart and funny
and kind and and pretty and all these
things and and it was really nice to
hear those things and I just kind of let
myself get swept into it to the point
where I wanted to try and fix things and
and tell my boyfriend about it but I
didn't even know where to begin so
that's kind of where it all started with
that
coworker
so
I most emotional Affairs happen on I
wish had a different word but on some
kind of Continuum or
Spectrum everything
from this person makes me feel so good
they laugh at my jokes they tell me I'm
beautiful like you they tell me I'm
smart and I'm starting to go to to them
for that affirmation when I should be
going to the person I'm exclusive with
or the person I'm
married emotional Affairs can
also have some real intimate like let's
talk let's talk about our spouses or
let's talk about our boyfriends and
girlfriends together or how they just
don't understand but you do right and it
kind of escalates a little bit emotional
Affairs can be um I love you let's meet
up and let's have lunch um emotional
affairs can someone somewhat and I don't
know how I would I have to sit down and
think this through but I'm just thinking
everything up to physical so we traded
topless pictures we've traded you know
in like stuff that we would never want
someone else to find out so when I lay
it out like that where are
you I it didn't escalate to the point
where it became like sexual it
definitely would I would say cross the
line of becoming romantic where
I started opening up about how just
being very vulnerable about things that
I shouldn't have been either like things
within my relationship that I was
unhappy about but also just the fact
that I'm unhappy with where I'm at in
life you know at at my age and at this
point in my life I thought I would be
married with kids by now and and I
brought this up to him and you know he
started to kind of say that I was
deserving of those things and that he
wanted to take me on a date and he
wanteded to see me in person and just
kind of like affirming those things that
I was opening up about so it didn't
cross the bounds of let's go hook up it
was more like romantic of like I want to
take you on a date and treat you well
and give you all the things that you
want
okay um and I want everyone listening to
get how dicey this how how slippery this
is right because I would tell you some
of what he told you like if you were
co-workers with me and you were like man
my marriage is a wreck and this and this
I would tell you I want more for you
than
that and then I would
say um I think y'all should go see
somebody and then I would say I really
want I wouldn't say I want to take you
on a date
right I don't know well I say that I
know more people than haven't that have
than haven't have found them themselves
in this situation okay so I want you to
know I don't think you're crazy I don't
think you're a terrible person thank you
I think you have a line that you crossed
and I think that's
important
and let me say this you have a line that
you've crossed I think that
is huge number two now boyfriend's
involved I don't like the way you
started the call because you started the
call with boyfriend found some text I
would love for you from this point
forward to begin to take 100% ownership
of what comes what has happen and what
comes next which is I crossed a line
with a cooworker others may not see it
as a big deal I didn't hold hands I
didn't make out I didn't send any like
topless photos I didn't do anything like
that but I know I crossed a line to
where I started thinking about this
person I started fantasizing about this
person I started wondering what my life
would be like with
them and
I have this this this long-term
boyfriend who thinks we exclusive and so
whatever the line is I want you to start
that way and then to come across uh and
then got to deal with boyfriend so what
is itth what boyfriend
find
so sorry I'm really nervous um oh you're
okay you're doing
great he found um some texts that were
just on my phone
where basically my cooworker was
offering to cook me dinner and inviting
me to come over and he was like Hey you
know I know about this coworker you've
told me about them I didn't know you
guys like change exchanged phone numbers
and were having these type of
conversations like it seems really
inappropriate and at that
moment I I know that this sounds bad but
I was waiting until after I talked with
you to be able to talk with him about it
because I didn't even know how to bring
it up so I was I genuinely wanted to
talk to him about it but I wanted to get
some advice first because searching on
the internet you find all sorts of
things you find people telling you to
never talk about it with them and just
pretend like it didn't happen and you
find people telling you that you need to
have them read every single text message
you ever sent and and completely open up
your phone to your boyfriend and I
understand both sides but it got to be
very confusing to what I should do so
when he when he asked me about it I was
honest and I told him when it started
and what when things crossed the line
and that's when my boyfriend started
asking if he could read the messages and
that was kind of also another question I
wanted to ask you is do you think that
it's helpful to have him read all those
text messages if I know that what's in
them could be hurtful for him
um I think he gets to decide
that okay because I think
that here's the thing going forward no
secrets and I trust you that when he
said hey what in the world's going on
like I knew about this guy and I know
you thought he was awesome I didn't now
he's offering to like have you over to
his house and make you food right like
that's an invitation for sex and I want
you to come over to my house and by the
way there's people who would read that
Exchange like yeah nothing really
happened here I could see where this
could go but nothing really happened
here so that's why what's important is
you saying no no no lines were
crossed even if we weren't physical I
know where my head was at and I felt so
alive when he asked me to come over and
I actually considered how would I make
this thing happen right you know all
those things I'm going to tell you that
Secrets will kill your relationship
that's number one number two I would ask
him if he was on the phone do you trust
her yes do you trust that nothing
happened physically yes do you trust
that y'all have some things youall have
to work out because this guy was able to
come in and say some things that Lit her
up like a Christmas tree yes I would
probably say do you need to go through
the nitty-gritty details of everything
and some people would say I do I won't
be able to sleep at night without
minding the whole thing and he gets to
say that and you get to decide
y or
nay I would probably tell him uh maybe
maybe not I know um and like me
personally I would I would want to see
every single
thing knowing that it would kill me and
I can name five friends on one hand like
on all five fingers on my right hand who
would not want to know like no I don't
need to see that I know we got some
stuff we got to deal with and whatever
so I'm going to go deal with it um but I
trust my wife she says she didn't do
that she didn't do that I trust my
girlfri and she said she didn't do that
she didn't do
that I think we have to sit down and say
you lead the charge again I want to
reiterate I messed up and I think it's
fair to say I didn't hold hands we
didn't kiss I didn't go to his house we
didn't meet secretly like but in my
heart I messed up that's number one
number two I have deleted
everything off social media off my phone
except for the the text messages unless
he wants to see them but I don't have a
way to access this person
anymore they are out of my life I've
asked my boss to not be in contact with
him or I have let them know hey we are
not communicating anymore my
relationship with my boyfriend is too
important period very very
clear go ahead yeah um I I also see what
you're saying where you're right I
didn't take accountability at the
beginning and I I I feel disgusted with
myself because I don't want to say that
you know this person did make me feel
alive and made me feel special and all
these things because you know I love my
boyfriend he's I love him to death like
he's my family I feel that way about his
family he feels that way about mine I
really he's the only person I've ever
dated that I could see a future with and
then I see him being my future spouse
but but hold on those aren't those
aren't mutually those aren't mutually
exclusive
and if you spend time talking to couples
it's
staggering how often something like this
happens somebody has a one night stand
somebody
has they they have an affair and by all
accounts their marriage is great they're
raising kids together they have a home
together they laugh they go on dates
they have a great sex life and then this
other thing happens over here that is
not weird or strange or out of the out
of the norm it doesn't um it blows a
hole in our fantasy that one um that the
perfect marriage means nothing can ever
happen that's not
true and what you're finding out is I
became somebody that I never thought I
would
be and your whole Foundation of who you
are has been shaken
fair fair yeah I mean my dad and my
stepdad both kind of did a similar thing
on my mom where they like basically
cheated with co-workers and I always
said that that wasn't going to be me
because I saw the harm that it did to
her I never wanted to be that person
okay can I can
I tell you I honor your anger and
frustration and discust with yourself
and you could have gone over there
couldn't
you if you had said hey I just got us a
room at the hotel meet me at 9:00
tonight he would have Shen up wouldn't
he yeah yeah and so I also at the same
time want to say you've got to reckon
with
you I also want to say but you held the
line both and
okay okay and I also want to acknowledge
and let's just put it out there we're
having the conversation we're already
here it was hard to hold the line wasn't
it yeah I mean a lot of the things that
he was saying were things that I felt
like I was dreaming to hear from someone
honestly I didn't want to tell my
boyfriend this is what you have to say
to me to make me feel good because that
feels fake that doesn't feel genuine
that feels inauthentic for me to tell
him this is what you have to say that's
a bull crap Hollywood Story
what your boyfriend has to know is
here's the things that make me feel
alive when you say this when you do this
then I feel
loved but right now you've been asking
him to read your
mind and he's unable to do
that and slowly you're dying
inside yeah and then a guy who cheats on
his
wife or wants to cheat on his wife wife
and by the way I hate to tell you this
you're not the only one in his
life but the person who cheats on his
wife happens to know the things to get
somebody fired
up happens to know all the right things
to
say I mean I think I partially felt less
guilty about it because he claims to be
like separated from his wife always do
they always
do they always are in the process of
breaking up or we've left each other or
there's always a
thing yeah always a
story and my boyfriend asked me like
what did I do wrong and it really makes
me feel I feel bad because you should he
really does think this is his fault and
how do I really explain to him that what
happened was not really his fault it was
my own fault I made the decision to
entertain it and to keep the back and
forth going you did and he's going to
he's an attentive boyfriend who loves
his girlfriend and he is going to have
to um wrestle with
that because he's going to want to solve
it and you're going to have to be honest
and open and say what I did what I chose
to do was my doing
and here's what I need moving
forward and I need you to be very clear
about what you need moving forward to
feel trust to feel safe to feel like I'm
all in okay if that's look at my phone
then that's look at my phone if that is
one of those apps that every text
message that comes in he gets a copy of
that text on his phone too okay we'll do
that for a season okay and if his
demands for what he's going to need are
too high you get to say no and your
relationship is
over okay what you can't do is try to
manage what he feels on his side he gets
to own that all of
it but I think it's fair to say this
this situation and by the way I don't
think it was just this guy I think he
happened to be
there I think your earlier comment in at
the beginning of this call was the most
honest thing you've said and that
is I I didn't want to feel like this but
suddenly I found myself feeling like
this I don't think it was him I think it
was any number of men could have filled
that role telling you that you have
value and that you're awesome and you're
hilarious and you're smart and they want
to spend extra time with you and they're
willing to break the rules of their
marriage and of society to be with you
it made you feel alive
again and so the Reckoning is can we
repair this relationship and rebuild
something new yes yes you
can boyfriend that I love what do you
need I'm all I'm wide
open and you have needs in this proc
rebuilding process too sometimes people
overcorrect and they dump everything
what do you need what do you need what
do you need I I I have to pay a Penance
so I get no say in the rebuild and
you're going to find yourself dead again
and this whole thing happens again so if
y'all both choose to rebuild he's
choosing to look at you and say what do
you need to feel alive here and you have
to get over that the that the world
isn't the notebook it isn't some
Hollywood show and you have to say the
things that you need I need you to tell
me you love me I need you occasionally
to laugh at my jokes even if they're not
that funny
occasionally remind me that I'm smart
and I have value and purpose around here
please will you
occasionally or often help out with the
dishes with the home offer to cook me a
meal you got to be open about those
things and he's probably been squashing
some things too it wouldn't surprise me
if he felt a little bit dead dead inside
also he gets to say all right while
we're here right this is a rebuild this
isn't a let's get back to the way things
were the way things were is over now and
you are going to have to work to trust
you again because you saw your dad do it
and you saw your stepdad do it and then
you found yourself right on the edge
leaning
over and again I want to end this call
with
this you held the
line you
crossed you know you fell for somebody
you had a crush on somebody you had
feelings for somebody
fair but you held the line and I'm proud
of you for that because that's
hard tonight you sit down with a
boyfriend and say I messed
up I want to rebuild this whole thing
from the floor up what are you going to
need and here's what I'm going to
need I'm in if you're in and by the way
all of this starts with you looking him
in the eye and say I will never contact
that person again and I will never
receive contact from that person again
period thank you so much for the call I
know this is scary and you um pretty
brave and millions and millions and
millions and millions of Americans are
experiencing this exact thing or have
it's
hard and I promise there's healing on
the other side if you both are in you're
awesome
Lynn